so talk a little bit about the two
gariands they're not they're Burrell's
newcomers to Westeros yes you know that
Targaryen czar of valerian descent and
the Freegold of alaria was the you know
the superpower of my my world for
hundreds of years there were sorcerer
Lords there who controlled certain dark
magics blood magic and fire magic
pyromancy and one of the things they had
was dragons and there were great Dragon
Lord families that bred and controlled
dragons and flew them into battle and
they they competed for primacy within
structure not dissimilar to the Roman
Republic where you know a certain number
of great families controlled everything
and most of the rest of the known world
could not stand against the Valerians
even when they had larger armies the
valerian advantage of dragons was too
great to overcome but four hundred years
ago the doom came the doom of Valyria
and the entire freehold of alaria was
was wiped out overnight and the
Dragonlords and hundreds of dragons with
it
the Targaryen had been one of the
families one of the bull agharti but
they had had a premonition that
something I just had common and they had
resettled to the dragon stone island off
the coast of Westeros sometime before
the the doom came total area and there
boy avoided that and it left them after
a relatively short period with the only
effective dragons in there in the world
and Aegon and his sisters used three of
those dragons to conquer the Seven
Kingdoms of Westeros